hello and welcome to cloud on-air live
webinars from Google cloud we're hosting
webinars every Tuesday
my name is tane buds dev and i work in
our cloud customer engineering team as a
security and compliance specialist you
can ask questions anytime on the
platform and we have Googlers on standby
to answer them so let me really start by
thanking you all for your time and
joining us also since we're covering a
decent amount of information in a short
amount of time
I just want to remind everyone that
everything that we go over today in this
session is something that is gonna be
covered in greater detail on our Google
cloud security and compliance website or
web page in the form of articles and or
white papers so in this session a few of
us will be talking about how to big
cloud computing company really
approaches things like security as a
whole compliance sharing data securely
and working securely from anywhere and
what that really means for you so I want
to first start by focusing on some of
the foundation so let's get started it
really begins with a single question
that every organization should be asking
themselves do you have a comprehensive
approach to security now this is
probably a question you've heard plenty
of times and I know that CEOs are often
asked this by their board of directors
because they tell us all the time so and
here's how we've learned to talk about
it so it really started with Google
being born and raised in the cloud and
has always run its services in a
multi-tenant cloud environment for that
time and moving forward we're now
fortunate enough to actually have seven
global services with 1 billion users
each as a result than you can imagine
we're pretty focused target for bad
actors so as you can imagine also then
having to figure out security privacy
and data compliance at such a large or
global scale is something that we had to
do quickly and effectively and not just
do it for the present time but also
future proofing the learnings we've had
from these problems really have turned
into the fundamental pillars for how how
we designer and secure our
infrastructure which happens to be the
same infrastructure that our enterprise
customers can and do use so because of
our relentless focus on protecting the
user we've learned and built systems in
turn for
structured and now enable things such as
what you're seeing on your screen now as
you can see we're making some bold
statements here well how are we able to
do these things so the vision and the
solution really starts and comes down to
a single enterprise technology platform
that automates many of today's security
practices and it frees IT teams to
innovate and serve better in other areas
of the enterprise it's what we use at
Google today and it's how we're actually
able to serve even you know the seven
Google businesses with 1 billion
customers each that we talked about
along with one of much of the world's
media and advertising businesses without
suffering the kind of security breaches
that typically put others and news
headlines because it's a single platform
without the versions and the layers of
different technology that create and the
most security gaps really we have speed
and scale that others simply just don't
every machine is up to date its patched
it's always available that accounted for
and there's no planned downtime and
actually the cool part is you can take
advantage of this technology with a
feature we call live migration something
that our customers that I talk to all
the time are pretty excited about
because the platform works with massive
amounts of data it's it's securely and
safely manages that data with
sophisticated encryption at rest and in
transit and because we believe that
cloud extends to on-premise data centers
as well as user devices it really turns
the employees from the greatest source
of risk to really your frontline
defenders to get a little bit more into
detail with though with our approach
take a look at this we actually call
this defense in depth and the idea
really is to approach or to protect your
organization by eliminating holes gaps
and flaws at every layer whether that be
the infrastructure the software or the
processes I'll touch on a few of those
with some examples and from the bottom
up so let's get started so to begin with
every layer is protected using
custom-built Hardware with no
unnecessary parts Google manufactures
almost all of its own hardware and any
third party never sees the overall build
process last year we deployed and
introduced a security chip called Titan
what Titan does and it's because it
installed in every Google server
it really checks them every machine for
integrity every time before it boots up
or while it's booting up and now in that
case a server is not allowed to jump on
the network it's holding and processing
zero data until its health has been
established and that's every single time
wherever possible we automate things
so we're relentlessly and repeatedly
checking code for vulnerabilities before
it's deployed we automatically encrypt
data at rest and in transit using on our
large and fast global network that I was
telling earlier about we maintain a
system of employee permissions and we
keep all the machines in the same state
we have a massive team of dedicated
security engineers and scientists that
are constantly testing the environment
for vulnerabilities and researching
patterns to figure out what future
vulnerabilities or threats could look
like so that we can protect Google well
in advance all right so I've talked
about our infrastructure I've talked
about our network I've talked about our
data management capabilities and our
automation at scale and not to mention
or not to forget our incredible
innovative security team but our vision
for the cloud does not really end here
we also include your on-premise data
centers in our security vision so we've
developed things such as cloud identity
which can help you manage access and
permissions on and off the cloud with
audit trails so you can actually stop
bad actors and establish compliant
policies kubernetes which hopefully all
of you have heard of by now a pretty
popular product nowadays and it's
something that is used for managing
sulfur containers inside our data center
inside your data center or across both
if you like and containers is really
what makes possible the kind of
system-wide automation patches that we
were talking about earlier now they give
our teachings better visibility into how
software is used and enables them to
innovate and inform others on things
such as cost performance and customer
product usage you may know that
kubernetes is available in other
platforms as well well that's because
one was being developed at Google we
open sourced it so that we could
actually make something as innovative
and it secures is available to the rest
of the community and the industry kind
of much much the way we did with Chrome
which is the most secure browser so it's
which is again an open-source platform
that Google contributes to and has done
a lot of work with and provides a
uniform way to connect manage and secure
micro services so a lot of customers I
talked to that are doing
containerization love sto and they
typically go hand in hand together and
lastly one of the things that's also
popular with some of the customers I
talked to especially when they're
focused on on-premise to begin with is
Apogee which is really what's something
that enables you to do more with your
data you can securely manage API calls
with other databases whether it's your
own or another one depending on your
strategic need so most of our customers
really start here and use Apogee
extensively at first to connect their on
premise systems and applications with
Google cloud so you can see on most of
these things we're talking about is open
source transparency and interoperability
is a core value at Google cloud while we
think our technology such as google
kubernetes engine is a really effective
way to go we're still big believers in
Portobello t so we believe that you
should take your workloads with you if
you choose to move and our customers
should be able to really move amongst
multiple cloud providers if they choose
to or do it all together and in a hybrid
environment and choose providers that
really give you the best and most
innovative services so all this really
brings us down to some of the last
thoughts I wanted to leave you with
which is our cloud trust principles
there's about five of them that I want
to talk to you about before I pass the
mic onto our next speaker so let's begin
with the first one know that your
security comes first and everything that
we do right secondly you control what
happens to your data every time third
know where Google stores your data and
rely on it being available every single
time you need it
fourthly depend on Google's
independently verified security
practices and last but not least trust
that we'll never give any government
entity backdoor access to your data or
to any of our servers that are storing
your data so I know we've covered a lot
of information in a short amount of time
here about how Google approaches and
secures our own infrastructure and what
that means for you but don't just take
our word for it
we believe in earning your trust through
transparency and not just through the
technology we've been
get out so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna pass the mic on and give you leave
you in the capable hands of James snow
who's going to talk to you about how
Google cloud approaches audits
compliance and what that means for you
thank you for your time
Thanks today
hello everyone I'm James snow I'm here
to talk to you today about security
compliance on the Google cloud platform
now to start the first question we often
have is what can google do with data
once it's been put onto our platform
otherwise known as scope of processing
the answer is very straightforward
Google can only use data on our platform
to provide the service that you as a
customer requested so we can only use
the data per your instructions and we
can use it for no other purpose so this
is outlined not only in our contracts
but it's also audited by third parties
but we'll get to that in just a moment
next is intellectual property who owns
the intellectual property for data that
is either uploaded or generated on our
platform again a very simple answer the
customer has a hundred percent of the IP
rights while Google has none last but
not least especially relevant in
regulated industry is around data
portability so if you move data onto the
Google cloud platform can you easily
move it off and the answer is yes at any
given time you can move your data on or
off our platform without requiring
assistance from Google with no fines or
fees etc and of course this comes off in
industry standard formats you could
think of kubernetes are our container
orchestration platform as the ultimate
embodiment of this philosophy where you
can move an active workload from on-prem
to Google's clouds to other clouds
dynamically in order to meet uptime
requirements to pivot and talk about
managing regulatory risk so oftentimes
working with regulated customers that
could be anything from national
regulation to healthcare to government
to finance there are lots of different
regulatory risks that customers are
exposed to now if you were to think like
a regulator the questions that they're
going to be asking is how are you
protected your regulated data who owns
that data where is it located and how is
it being used last but not least if the
data is supposed to be deleted how is
that done securely and efficiently now
at Google we have a single cloud
platform so this actually makes it
easier for a lot of regulated in
because we operate a baseline of
security controls across our entire
platform so it's not one solution has
one level of security or one product has
one level security it applies across our
entire platform we are recovered
ownership in usage the customer owns the
data and it can only be used for their
instructions data location is
configurable per product that we have on
the Google cloud platform at all times
it is going to be transparent and
customers will know where their data is
at any given moment data deletion so
Google is a what we call a data
processor the customer is the data
controller if the data controller gives
Google and instruction to delete data we
as the data controller will execute
their instruction faithfully and
thoroughly so let's talk about how
Google thinks about privacy and
compliance and security all of these
topics are interrelated now in a
traditional IT system this usually
starts the other way around they'll say
I need to process or protect credit card
data so I need to build a PCI DSS
environment now that's a starting point
for many but for Google it's really
reversed we look at our entire platform
and we say what are the strongest
security controls that we can put in
place across our entire platform next
we'll look at the privacy controls the
management of the data the axis of the
data and being able to monitor that
effectively last but not least we'll
look at the compliance frameworks that
we can put on top of it because we have
this uniform security we can actually
start looking at things like independent
security and compliance certifications
as applying across our platform and not
for specific solutions or projects so
let's talk about our independent
third-party certifications so please the
big difference I want to impart here is
that we operate a single cloud
environment we have one global cloud we
do not have a German cloud or healthcare
cloud or financial services cloud or
even a gov cloud we operate a single
cloud infrastructure and what that means
is again not just having a single
baseline but having an audited baseline
again against multiple
standards by multiple auditors so let's
talk through a few of the biggies so we
have the ISO certifications this is an
international family of standards
starting with ISO 27001 we have a
hundred and fourteen security controls
looking at our platform ISO 27000 17 is
an evolution with cloud specific
security controls ISO 27000 and
is the first cloud data privacy standard
so this is the third party audit that's
attesting that your data is only being
used per your instruction and for no
other purpose if you're more the report
reading type of security professional we
have our sock one sought - and sought
through security reports this is about
350 pages of security goodness that you
can review and of course match to your
controls or your requirements if you'd
like to process credit card data we have
PCI DSS certification of course we have
the most recent certification and we
operate at the highest merchant level so
we can meet your requirements in terms
of credit card processing if you're a
healthcare professional we have HIPPA
that we actually support the
requirements under HIPAA so we will
enter into a baa
we just recently attained our high trust
certification focused on health care
data last but not least and this is a
large differentiation for our platform
is FedRAMP authorization so FedRAMP is
the security standard that's used for
protecting data at both the federal
state and local levels now on other
platforms they have very specific
government clouds that meet these
standards at Google we have a global
platform so all of our data centers our
services that are scoped under FedRAMP
are all covered by these protections and
we make these same services of course
available to all customers not just
government agencies so if you're a bank
or in your healthcare your data is being
protected at the same standard that we
use for the US government but it's not
just FedRAMP you have multiple audits
the FedRAMP bought it the ISO audits the
sock audits multiple checks multiple
times to ensure that your data is being
protected at the standards that have
been promised now these are the
independent third-party certifications
we also have
a lot of regulatory engagement so being
on that single cloud platform is very
important because we have the exact same
story that we can bring to all of the
regulators globally across different
industries we're working with national
banks or working with with healthcare
oversight authorities we're working with
privacy authorities in Europe we're
working with them not just to explain
our platform and to quantify and
validate our contracts but again we want
to have a consistent picture for both
compliance and security across multiple
geographies so if you're a multinational
organization you can have one solution
that's going to be able to protect all
of your users rather than just having
something that is regional alright so
speaking of something that is a national
level and topical of late I'd like to
talk about the GDP are the GDP are is
the EU general data protection
regulation this affects and protects the
personally identifiable information of
European nationals basically it puts in
controls and restrictions on what can be
done with their data and of course it
gives them rights to be protected and
notified if there are things like data
breaches or security incidence now
Google has been working very hard and we
are compliant with this regulation both
as a company and as a provider of
services via our enterprise cloud now
this matters to most customers because
oftentimes most companies are actually
interacting or collecting this type of
information but again you do not need to
make that differentiation because we
operate as one cloud we're protecting
all data to the same level that the gdpr
requires not just a specific subset so
again this is about making things easier
for you the gdpr is Evolutionary not
revolutionary for years Google has been
compliant with the EU Data Protection
Directive the regulation that came
before the gdpr
and we've been working for years to
become compliant with the gdpr as a
cloud provider now when I say it's
evolutionary its evolutionary in a very
positive term for both data subjects and
for you as a customer under the old law
the Data Protection Directive only you
the customer will respond
constable for compliance you're also
responsible for paying all these fines
under the GDP our this is all changed
under the GDP our security and
compliance are a shared responsibility
between you and Google for the areas
that Google is responsible for we're
responsible for directly to the privacy
authorities if there is some sort of
incident or problem it's Google who will
be held responsible and Google will be
paying the fine we're here to partner
with you to help mitigate that risk and
of course protect your information okay
I think that's all for today I hope you
learned a lot today about what you need
to each know about staying compliant and
thank you for your time
hi my name is mike ayello I'm the
director of product management for cloud
security I'm here today to talk about
securing and sharing your data so as a
chief security officer a chief
information officer chief risk officer
you need to manage risks differently
when you move to Google cloud this is
where most of your new analysis and
benefit of moving to the cloud is going
to come from but this drives changes in
enterprise culture in audit governance
administrative control and in order to
manage these risks you need to think
hard about what the root cause of most
of the risks are and we find it comes
from three sources poor data management
practices unauthorized access control
and access control set up and
unencrypted data on the cloud at Google
we're proud to say that we have an array
of solutions with addressing these
concerns that are part of the shared
responsibility between the user of
Google cloud and Google cloud itself so
let's go through them first we want to
talk about the exceptional opportunity
for customer understanding product
design manufacturing planning there's a
whole bunch of benefits that you get
from moving to cloud and the core of
that is the analytics workflow that
comes from from coming from cloud but
this also means that you have more data
in more places previously it was only on
Prem now it's on Premanand cloud and
across potentially multiple clouds and a
big part of this the big part of reason
you do this is because you want to
enable data sharing the reality is in
order to get real value out of cloud you
need to move sensitive information or
private information to cloud or
anonymize versions of private
information in cloud one of the examples
that we have is we worked with a
healthcare customer who took more than
two years to simply identify and
discover the private and sensitive
information that they had in their
enterprise before they began their
adoption of cloud at Google we've
invested deeply in machine learning and
artificial intelligence to create tools
and products that make moving to cloud
easier and make the data discovery and
data anonymization aspects easier what
you're seeing here is a output of one of
our products called the data loss
prevention API which has automatically
discovered sensitive information in a
file that was passed through the API and
automatically in place format preserving
redacted that information so you can see
that the phone numbers have been
redacted except for the first three
digits and email addresses and social
security number
have been redacted this makes it much
easier to tell the story of securely
operating analytics environments in the
cloud because you can do so on anonymize
and redacted data we're also deeply
invested in making sure that you have
transparency into when a Googler
accesses your data so we've invested in
a product called access transparency
which you can enable which gives you a
notification whenever a Googler accesses
your data for example if you send in a
support ticket asking for help with a
specific storage bucket that yeah so
we're excited about having tools and
products that help you discover and
classify your information and
additionally giving you enhanced
transparency when you keep sensitive
information in Google Cloud now let's
talk about access control the idea that
people should access what they need for
their jobs and nothing else it's a it's
a good fundamental principle of security
at its core its defining who can do what
on which resource so if you think about
who that's the identity of the user can
do what that's the action on which
resource this is the resource within the
cloud storage process etc we have two
key principles that we'd like to
communicate about this first is
establish the most granular access
policy as you can it's the principle of
least privilege and we provide an
identity access management solution to
do this and then second is employee
multi-factor authentication to protect
against phishing we found that this
reduces one of the most common attack
vectors that we see in 2018
significantly finally let's talk about
securing the bits encryption 59% of
companies today lack an enterprise-wide
encryption strategy that's not good
there's many companies out there that
don't have a story they can tell their
board about data being encrypted by
default across the entire enterprise
you'll be happy to know that as you move
your data to Google Cloud we take care
of that we encrypt the data by default
we encrypt it with the same processes
and procedures we use to encrypt data
across Google and have spent a long time
working on these processes and
procedures we have a core principle that
you should have control of the keys that
encrypt your data if you so choose and
we provide a range of management options
for those keys so by default like I
mentioned your data is encrypted by rest
with keys that Google manages at the
other extreme is you can bring your own
encryption keys this gives you the
maximum control you're providing the key
material which encrypts your data
and in the middle we provide a customer
manage encryption key option where we
generate the keys for you and you can
control the rotation and revocation
periods around these keys so in order to
encrypt your data and secure your data
you need a range of options from a
fundamental perspective the data is
encrypted by default at Google and we
can help you in each of these choices
that you have as you talk about
encryption with your customer base with
your board and with Google and we see
every permutation of encryption key
management that folks can think of folks
have come to us and talked about how
they want encryption to work and we
believe our product suite solves the
vast majority of these use cases and if
it doesn't solve all of them please come
back and talk to our team and we will we
will work to make the products better so
with that I wanted to say thank you and
I want to hand it over to Reena who's
going to talk about how to work securely
from anywhere
thank you Michael and hello everyone i
am reena Nadkarni product management
lead on the g suite team G suite is
Google's productivity suite it includes
all of the products that you're familiar
with like gmail calendar Google Drive
Docs and editors with extra controls for
enterprise users and enterprise admins
my focus today is primarily on security
and how to make it simple you can have
all the security tools in the world but
they're only useful if you actually
deploy them we want to make security
simple both for the IT admins as well as
for the enterprise and users so what can
we do to make security easy to use is it
possible to change the paradigm from the
old world where employees are the
greatest source of vulnerability the
most mistrusted area to switching it
around and making them the front line of
defense at Google we have a history of
making difficult things simple to use
think about quality search results
that's something that's very complex has
a lot of sophisticated technology behind
the scenes but we've made it really
simple for our end users security is no
exception to many this might seem
counterintuitive security implies levers
dials lots of rules and engines easy
implies exactly the opposite making
security easy might scare some people
but I would argue that the failure to
not achieve this goal is far worse
because then security gets in your way
and people are not really using the
security tools we make available so with
great urgency we're driving towards the
world that solves this problem let's
think about the way in which many people
still work today passwords being managed
across different systems some systems
required passwords that have 12
characters others want a mix of upper
and lower characters some require
special characters
and many times people simply pick
passwords write them on a post-it stick
them in their cube or on their screen
many people are still using thumb drives
for data portability and countless hours
are being spent in attending trainings
and developing trainings around
compliance the trainings that I like to
call thou shalt not do X Y or Z so let's
start to think about how we get control
over all these issues and how we can
solve these problems by knowing the
risks to understand the landscape a
little bit better let's look at what's
been happening in the world of data
breaches and the world of ransomware
there has been a 15 X increase in
ransomware losses between the last 2015
to 2017 last couple of years employees
are more vulnerable than ever
90 percent of all reported breaches were
caused by unintentional employee
negligence these bad actors prey on your
vulnerable employees data breaches when
compounded over time are estimated to
have a collective cost of two point one
trillion dollars by 2019 so it's really
easy to understand why we need solutions
that not only help the IT admins but
also empower the enterprise end users so
now let's see how a cloud native
solution can help in security scale
matters it's almost like we constantly
see these new attacks and flaws from
using old methods and outdated patches
this is because we are running a network
that carries one-fourth of the Internet
traffic we stop more than anyone else
and are uniquely equipped to address
them all did you know that every minute
Gmail stops 10 million spam and
malicious emails from reaching our end
users we've also recently added advanced
poofing protections in Gmail we've added
Gmail confidential
which allows you to set message
expiration revoke send messages and also
limit attachment downloads and
forwarding to keep your confidential
data safe we talked a little bit about
scale the scale that we have allows us
to apply advanced AI and ML techniques
to the domain of security as you know
machine learning models scale better
based on the data that you have to train
these models on our machine learning
models train on data generated from
seven products that have over a billion
monthly active users secondly when you
think about attacks like DDoS attacks
you want to have a bandwidth a high
bandwidth Network we have the network
that allows you to watch 500,000 YouTube
videos in high-definition simultaneously
and then think about device protections
we protect three billion devices from
URLs with malicious content every day
and with Google this scale and security
is now available to protect you your
corporation and your employees and their
data so let's talk about some specific
features that we have to be able to make
your employees less vulnerable and more
powerful the first I want to start with
a statistic zero zero is the number of
account hijackings we have seen detected
or reported from our customers ever
since they have deployed security keys
so this is a very simple and very
important security protection that you
can use for your organization's second G
speed data loss prevention both in Gmail
and in Google Drive at scale we can stop
important data from being exfiltrated
outside your organization's and we make
it really simple for you to set up these
rules the DLP rules we have over 50
predefined content types that cover
confidential data across the world so
that you can create very
easily there's advanced DLP rules but we
also allow you to create custom rules so
that you can protect data let's say that
you have a confidential project name and
you want to make certain that the data
related to this project never goes
outside of your organization you can set
up a DLP rule to protect that and you
can take a variety of different actions
for example you can quarantine that
email from going out you can warn the
user or you can do both and lastly we
now have security center for G suite
what security Center for G suite does is
that first of all it has a set of
dashboards that consolidates data from
across the organization things like
login audit mobile device management
alerts as well as suspicious drive
activity all in one place so as an admin
you can come in and get a single view of
the security posture of your
organization
second we have consolidated all the
security settings for your organization
in one place and we show you google
recommended best practices of what those
settings should be to best protect your
organization so what you really see is a
health check of your organization
security settings all the settings in
one place what Google recommends are the
best practices as well as what settings
you have and where you're deviating from
our best practices this has been really
useful for our IT admins to get at a
glance in one view and then finally we
have created an investigation tool that
allows you to very quickly take actions
this is because when a malicious email
enters into your organization the time
that you have to protect your data
requires you to act very quickly so what
we do is we allow the admins to very
quickly navigate across different
corpuses of data from mobile logins into
suspicious drive activities and narrow
down the data that you're seeing and
very quickly take actions bollock
actions like deleting emails now clearly
this is a very powerful capable
and so we want to make sure that it's
available only to the super admins with
very delegated and privileged access so
we talked about three things first how
you can protect your organization by
deploying security keys second how you
can proactively set up DLP rules to
better protect your organization's data
and finally how G speed security Center
helps your organization get one stop
view of the security posture and very
quickly act upon malicious incidences
with that I want to thank you for
watching I really hope you enjoyed this
talk and will end with some insights
from one of our customers the city of
Los Angeles I'd like to now hand it over
to Ted Ross who is the general manager
and CIO thank you
[Music]
my name is ted ross and i'm chief
information officer at the city of los
angeles as the IT department for the
second-largest city in the united states
we have plenty of challenges
we're relied upon by many other city
departments that includes LA police
department libraries Recreation and
Parks building and safety planning and
many others in the beginning people
thought of the cloud as being something
a little more risky because your data is
no longer on-premise something that you
can touch but we're really way past that
point security and cloud is
exponentially better than what most
organizations can provide on-premise in
2018 and we moved our financial system
into the cloud which means hundreds of
thousands of transactions every year are
running out of the cloud by moving data
up into the cloud how long do we get a
low-cost
pay-as-you-go infrastructure that's
secure and resilient but we also get
access to great machine learning and
artificial intelligence tools that allow
us to gain a much more insight into our
operations how we run our city the
decisions that we make and we can do so
with powerful tools that we wouldn't be
able to access within our data center
in 2017 we had a very unique situation
to multi alarm fires occur in Los
Angeles at the same time we had to get
communications out to over 150,000
residents who had to be evacuated so
while we did it with all the traditional
means of news stories and radio reports
etc we were missing a digital solution
we leveraged Google Maps to very quickly
put together layers very simple layers
to communicate where the fire
evacuations were the use of Google Maps
for fire evacuation was so effective
that we actually had over three million
views within 36 hours and honestly you
will not find such a high level of
consumption for almost anything
government knows we feel that cloud
infrastructure is absolutely the way of
the future
allows us to deliver great technology
that's robust its resilient to disasters
and it scales at internet scale we find
G suite tools to be an extremely
effective way of empowering our
employees here is a service and here's a
tool that makes our employees much more
productive whether they're sharing
documents or sharing spreadsheets
sharing information their ability to do
this so quickly and so efficiently
really is much more cost effective for
the taxpayer for an organization our
size lightweight tools like Google's
gives us tremendous opportunities
honestly the more we move into the cloud
the more we see the benefits from a
resiliency perspective from a security
perspective and just from an
accessibility perspective
you